An air defense says they were able
to destroy dozens
of Russian missiles and drones
that took part
in an early morning attack.
Authorities say the two Ukrainians,
including an 11 year
old child, were injured by falling debris
Also today, more attacks
inside Russia,
according to officials there.
They say Ukrainian shelling in the border
region of Belgorod killed two people.
And an official in western
Russia says two drones
struck fuel facilities.
Now, early this week,
a drone attack on Moscow left
at least two people injured
and several buildings damaged.
There was a significant turn in a war
that until recently had left Russia
largely untouched.
Today, Vladimir
Putin appeared
to acknowledge
these strikes on his country,
calling them attempts
to destabilize
and, quote, stir up the situation
within the Russian Federation.
Our Fred
Pleitgen joins us
now from Ukraine
with a look inside the drone war.
Fred, can you just talk about
how things have changed for Ukrainians
with this now
constant threat of drone strikes
Well, it's certainly changed
a great deal.
And I think for a lot of people, it's
really unnerving,
especially here in the capital, Kiev.
Anderson, I can tell you
there's a lot of nights where people here
just simply don't get any sleep
because they live in fear
the entire time.
And the way that these drone attacks work
is they usually have swarms
of those charged drones
as Iranian made drones
coming towards the Ukrainian capital.
You hear the engines hover above you
and you hear the Ukrainians
trying to take them down.
But of course,
what's happening
now is that the Ukrainians
are fighting back.
They've launched their own
mass live drone program.
It's a huge priority for the Ukrainians
with which they can now
project power deep,
not only into Russian held territory,
but into Russian territory as well.
Here's what we're learning.
Can this fly into Russia?
Yes.
Valery Breivik's
company
makes combat drones
for Ukrainian frontline troops
and they allowed us to film
test flights at a secret location.
He says reaching Moscow is not a problem.
We have bigger draw
for and 700 kilometers with war
has had 20 kilograms and that could fly
almost almost overnight.
Yes,
While Ukraine denies direct involvement
in the recent Moscow drone attack,
Kiev has drastically expanded
its use of drones
for everything from surveillance
to directly
bombing Russian ground troops.
Cheap, easy to use and lethal UAV.
Considered toys
are now vital to Kiev's war effort
The Ukrainians say for them,
drones are the big equalizer in this war.
They say
the Russians have more tanks,
more artillery and more planes.
But the Ukrainians
have the creativity of their population.
This is a drone competition
organized by Ukraine's government,
with simulated attacks on ground targets
chasing fixed
wing drones
and even drone
dogfights.
We were granted
exclusive access on the condition
we don't reveal the location.
It's like a start up fair for SPV.
Your first person view,
drones, small UAV
that can drop mortars
and grenades
flown by pilots wearing VR goggles
from a makeshift trench
to simulate the battlefield.
So
for us,
our drones are very easy to use,
especially if the pilot has flown
similar drones
I think they will intuitively understand
how they work.
The stakes are immense.
A general involved
in drone procurement for Ukraine's
military tells me
that this could risk
to complaining about.
30 companies in Ukraine
are already mass producing these drones.
And our goal
is to purchase up
to 200,000 by the end of the year.
Their backs up against the wall.
When Russia's
massive army invaded last year,
the Ukrainians quickly
realized cheap air power could help
keep them in the fight.
First, using modified
consumer drones,
now with more sophisticated
UAV is developed in Ukraine.
What the government here
calls the Army of Drones
Project
spearheaded by the Minister
of Digital Transformation.
So the completion of
this is a technological war,
and it's very important to understand
how technology is developing
and what we as a state can do to increase
the number of drones.
A certain revolution is also taking place
regarding production scaling the most of
this time.
And while the Ukrainians
still won't admit direct involvement,
the Russians do admit
they are concerned
they might soon see more armed drones
flying towards Moscow.
It's incredible to see it
up close like that, Fred.
Is there any indication
when we could see these drones
Ukraine is purchasing, you know,
above the battlefield in in the fight
Well, I think it could be very soon.
You know,
some of the drones that we saw there
at that drone competition,
they've already been on the battlefield,
but in small quantities.
And I think one of the things, Anderson,
that we all need to understand
is that on every battlefield
here in Ukraine, whether it's Bermuda,
whether it's in the south,
in the rear echelon
of those battlefields,
you always have a small little shop
that's developing new drones
and that's trying to improve
some of the drones
that are already there, for instance,
to make it impossible for the Russians
to go locate
the person who's operating the drone
or to make it impossible
to hack into those drones.
So that's already happening all the time.
Well, the government here tells me is
they want to make it
as quick as possible,
that they find a startup, identify
that that startup could help them
and then scale up production
as fast as possible
so we could see some of these drones
on the battlefield very soon Anderson.
It's incredible.
Fred Pleitgen, appreciate it.
Perspective now
from CNN military analyst, retired Army
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling.
I mean,
the use of drones is so interesting,
not only in this war,
but in all future conflicts.
But what do you make of
how drones are being used right now
in the war in Ukraine?
Well, they're the insertion
of these private sector
operators is very good, Anderson.
You know,
these are not that new
drones have been around for a while.
I had back in 2008 when I was in Iraq.
All of our units had small what we called
raven drones,
which were literally hand
launched, would give infantry units
the opportunity
to see ahead of them in the battle
to even look inside buildings at times.
So Ukraine is actually taking this
to a new level.
The drones in the past,
the unmanned aerial systems,
as we like to call them,
are something that is an advancement
on the battlefield today.
But I got to tell you
what we've seen in terms of using drones
in Ukraine beyond Reconoce fence,
but to actually drop munitions to
counter electronic warfare.
These are some new opportunities,
I think, in warfare
and is certainly going to change
the scene.
We're learning a lot from Ukraine
and their use of drones.
So do you think that the U.S.
military is looking at that as something
they may want to incorporate
or figure out how to incorporate
or explore more?
Oh, we've been looking at it
for a long time, Anderson.
In fact,
at our training centers
five or six years ago,
they actually introduced drone swarms.
We saw those kind of things in the war
between Armenia and Azerbaijan
just a few years ago
when there were opportunities
to destroy tanks with drones.
And in the
in the battle in Nagorno-Karabakh,
it was an area where surprised
a lot of people,
Iranians have been using them
for a very long time.
But again, the publication
and the social media aspect of
what's been happening in Ukraine,
I think it's surprised a lot of people
who don't know that
drone warfare
is now a part of the modern battlefield.
But this has been going on
for quite some time.
But a great report by Fred
Pleitgen just now.
Yeah, to see the private
sector components. Fascinating.
Russia's defense ministry said today
a group of Chechen special forces
have begun
an offensive in eastern Ukraine.
Obviously, we've heard a
lot about the volunteer forces.
There were probably Chechens
involved in that as well.
But there were Chechens
involved early on in the attempt
to decapitate the leadership
in Kiev in the first days of this war.
We haven't heard much about them
over the last year or so.
Do you think that I mean,
is that significant
that they're announcing
that there's Chechens now?
Yeah, I don't believe it is, Anderson.
What we've seen.
Excuse me, is Mr.
Putin attempting
to get a variety of groups
to do his fighting for him?
And part of the reason for that is
there are people who are selling him
on these groups,
being capable of conducting operations
when they're really not
They're used to certain
kinds of battlefields
destroying things
like they did in Chechnya, in Syria.
Excuse me.
And they don't take the place of good,
well-trained soldiers who are well-led
on the battlefield,
under NATO supervision.
They're just
a bunch of thugs
and private military corporations
Part of it
seems to be also psychological.
You know that,
as you said, that
there's a lots of people in the fight,
but also that Chechens have a reputation
of just being thugs and brutal and.
Yeah, just horrific.
Yeah.
And I'm not sure how to compare them
to the Wagner group.
And I'm not sure
you can get more thuggish
than the kind of prisoners that Mr.
Prigozhin recruited
in the last phase
of the Battle of Back Moon.
But again,
it's just trying to throw a bunch of
free floating electrons on
to the battlefield
that aren't in very large groups
or don't have any operational savvy.
They're just flat out killers. Right.
But when you don't have the capability
to conduct operations, either
offenses or defenses,
and you're just throwing yourself
into the fight with a weapon,
things don't end up doing well.
And we've seen that
with the Wagner Group.